- 24 months of
eating shit to be able
to caviar for the
rest of your life.
("Monday To Monday"
by Saba)
Saba mother fuckers.
I've been telling you.
- [Gary] Yo, what up everyone?
Happy Saturday.
Hope life is good.
Just really
appreciate all of you.
Thank you so, so
much for all the love.
Just thank you.
Today's DailyVee is
all about Mike Playa.
Playa's good
friend, Jets friend.
My brother Alex's good
friend from post-college.
We became super friendly.
He was in the ticket business,
then he came and
worked at Vayner for a year.
Actually, there's something
most people don't know about
VaynerToys when Mike was the
foremost expert in
Teenage Mutant--
- Gary, doesn't like
to talk about VaynerToys.
- I don't like to
talk about failures.
We'll tell the story
about VaynerToys actually in a
different episode.
Maybe I'll do it
today when I walk.
But now is crushing it and now
we're talking about his next
chapter and giving
Benji Kleiner shout outs.
- It's all
about Hamilton, folks.
- Hamilton.
Life advice for
youngsters is always part of the
equation on a random Saturday.
So, two quick things.
Number one, this tweet
about eating shit went out
(bird tweet)
and caught a lot of
people's attention and thought
I'd expand on it.
I just am surprised by how many
of you don't realize that the
leverage in the world
is always the thing that
is less obvious to the masses.
Meaning giving is a better
strategy than taking
over the long-term.
So I'm just gonna give as much
as I can on this channel and
then eventually, one day somehow
you might owe me a favor.
Eating shit and taking it and
being the bigger man and woman
in every situation which is my,
which is really my definition of
eating shit is
something I do every day.
Every day 95% of the
time, I have the leverage
but I don't use it.
And to me, that is leadership.
To me, that's
playing the long game.
building relationship.
To me, that's
building confidence.
To me, that's up a million
different things that
I think a lot of people
misunderstand and is the thing
that really separates
the winners from losers in my
opinion in society because
I think it's super easy to throw
around your big stick
at every moment but I think
eventually you you
run out of haymakers.
You become a weird version of
the boy that cries wolf and so
for me I'm pretty
passionate about
really focusing on eating shit.
On looking at the comments
and laughing them off.
On allowing my managers
to get away with
something this time.
Just a lot of versions of it.
Just, it's actually so
kind of hardwired in me.
It's very similar to
the customer's always right.
Just deploying enormous empathy.
I just eat shit constantly.
I love watching people thinking
they're getting away with it but
they're just creating checkmarks
in the loss column that
I'll eventually expose
or use or act on
or not I mean my preference
is I never have to act on it
and I can play that 51/49.
Now VaynerSports, 'round
when the hurricane came here
to New York, back in the day
Mike, who you saw earlier,
was trying to convince him to
leave his job 'cause I thought
he had a lot more talent and
as a middle move I created a
business called VaynerToys,
might have just said sports by
the way,
VaynerToys and him and Lou,
who works at VaynerMedia now,
and a friend that I grew up
selling baseball cards with
Lee Platt and a cousin of mine
Sean Gorelick and ultimately
that was model issue, right?
Hit the button
there by accident.
Ultimately that was the
the issue with the business.
There was too much overhead
against the strategy but it was
basically VaynerToys was
the 2017 eBay Flip Challenge.
I have this really
interesting 2017 challenge.
It is my belief that everybody
has a ton of tchotchkes.
We're gonna have
a $20,170 challenge.
Could we create a side business
that could make hundreds of
thousands of dollars by buying
and selling stuff from
thrift stores, garage sales,
you know, junk auctions.
The answer is the
revenue was there.
I created too much of the
infrastructure because I was
trying to really build a team
around a lot of my homies and
and so the
dollars were there but
I treated too much
like a hobby business.
I treated too much like a place
to put a bunch of my friends and
cousins and relatives and
relationships and ultimately we
were just losing money,
there's no reason to do it but
I absolutely believe, and
especially since I've seen
what's going on now, it
empowered me to very much
believe that
there was 30, 40, 50,
60, 70, 80, $90,000
a year in profit
to be made if you took
this seriously and
what I love about
life is I really focus on
every negative becoming a
positive and going through that
confirming what AJ and I were
doing by seeing what VaynerToys
short six months looked
like confirmed and gave me the
audacity to create the 2017 Flip
Challenge that hundreds of you,
thousands of you are
going to be impacted on.
I cannot wait for the end of
this year to watch all the
people who bought
homes, paid off loans,
bought a car, went on a family
vacation all because of a piece
of content I created and
that makes me super happy.
Oh and a quick PS.
Little clip from two
years ago on #AskGaryVee,
Instagram game is
really fascinating to me.
Betting hard on it.
All you entrepreneurs should.
A little rant I had
about Instagram.
It's been fun to
see that play out.
It is the number one
social network as the
attention graph
goes, by the way,
I need to desperately
make an attention graph.
Like we gotta get into like that
'cause that's what I care about.
Over time and and that's
one of the great things about
documenting all of this.
Being able to do
these fun recalls.
Two years ago,
if you were on this train,
if you were paying attention
you might've gone deep into the
Instagram game that I'm trying
to really focus a lot of you
guys on and really
that's my biggest number one.
Like I'm gonna give out the
value and I hope you act on it.
See you tomorrow.
(rock music)